hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be checking out the video from
watchmojo.com top ten sexy female movie
villains like me a badass chica you know
what I mean I wanted to just give you
guys a heads up I'm going to be out of
town for the next three days and I'm not
going to have any service I'm going on a
camping trip slash music festival I'm
hoping there's a lot of drugs there a
lot of drugs I need to take as many
drugs as possible this weekend in hopes
that I come back alive to continue doing
reaction reviews for you guys before
that I wanted to check this video out
girlfriends gone so let's see what this
is about
they make bad look so good
welcome to watch women Tasha heads
through the top ten sexy female movie
villains is it cold in here just to give
all the evil gals of Photoshop yeah
she's not counting cartoon characters or
comic book super villains aliens are
fair game though as long as they're hot
Natasha she's rich it quick through
number 10
Laurie Quaid totals you know she used to
be really she's still pretty good for
age you know the girl of my dreams
kicking off our list is Sharon Stone as
the seemingly loving wife to our knees
memory altered hero togs
I said totnes your life I held you not I
swear to God I never saw you before six
weeks ago her marriage is just a memory
implant there to keep an eye on him
she's actually a deadly agent whose
function is to act as a fail-safe in
shooting enemies return honey you
wouldn't hurt me would you sweetheart
pretty sure please enough Kate
Beckinsale rocks the same role but takes
it to new acrobatic and lethal Heights
if living a lie came with either these
ladies as a perk would it really be so
bad Oh considered that definitive of
course number nine Madison lead oh yeah
go frog yeah hello angels oh yeah
Addison Lee Demi Moore plays a rogue
Charlie's Angel one that quit the
crime-fighting biz to become a master of
Sasha if a she sang commando bullets up
her an angel when I can play God
stunning despite having some extra years
on the current team she's not only a
brilliant fighter but rocks and Nobel
Prize in astrophysics is never good
that's great I'd still do her once I
tried not just looks but brains as well
consensus is it you ready
are you number eight
Baroness GI Joe the rise of Cobo is I
might actually like it oh yeah
similar general with glasses business
first it took a special actress to
portray the glasses and leather-clad
russian intelligence officer of Cobra
nice shoes for Sienna Miller brings the
look if not the accent - the ruthless
role a certified badass despite being
the product of brainwashing she lays a
serious beatdown on all the Joe's and
their headquarters guess so huh
surprisingly she also toys with mends
and motions [ __ ] I told you kill him if
he touched you again I heard you the
first time
number seven TX Terminator 3r I actually
don't think she's as hot as a lot of
people think she is I like this car yeah
good things on a matter of all packages
she's not shocked take it the deadliest
of the terminators come wrapped in
supermodels Christina lokan plays this
emotionless killer to her strengths
using her piercing stare to show that
she means business not terminators don't
blink
she just blinked
sure it's all that Skynet equipped it's
liquid metal hybrid the ability to
increase her bust size but you can't
argue with the results
number six dr. Julia Oh bosses so for
now I was her employee in this movie
tell me you know when and if I cross the
line okay okay now this film was about
you guessed it bosses that you don't
want hoshi Sud sex shoes yeah taking a
page out of Demi Moore's disclosure
handbook Jennifer Aniston plays a
dentist who sexually harasses her male
assistant in all the wrong ways oh I
think I couldn't make out our little
friend right there alone somebody's
circumcised okay while he's engaged to
be married
this simply dodged appraised janitor my
[ __ ] little mouth oh you say sometimes
I mean who talks like that
sure she's not on my life threatening
villain but when you mess with a man's
relationship the gloves come off
because if there's so much as look and
my sexy little ass Julia I want yours
locked the cop you crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
number five Regina George
uh yeah I'm from how she used to be a
child like her better with red hair like
your typical selfish backstabbing but
Chicago bash but in reality she's so
much more than this backstabbing female
antagonist is played by the Omaha she
does they could be holy [ __ ] oh my god I
love your skirt where did you get it uh
it was my mom's with eighties vintage
hey that is the ugliest effing skirt
I've ever seen the only difference is
that in this film she actually plays a
memorable highschool bully who goes
above and beyond all the mean traits
that would categorize her as vindictive
trang pak is Ostrovsky little [ __ ]
still true Don Schweitzer is a fat
version still have true yeah these range
from being incredibly controlling and
deceitful all the way to belittling
others
do you want to have sex with him no
thank you good so it's settled so you
can go shave your back now by dancing
one thing's for sure this princess is
not completely right in the head number
four xenia onatopp gold oh when I was
six years old
I was you know not touching my [ __ ] I
was before things actually
Jean Grey and Phoenix famke Jensen was
leaving bond breathless I really thought
she was not Nationality a Russian X Air
Force pilot turned a member of Yanis she
gets to bring her kinky murderous
tendencies to work she's so stunning
that we can't help but feel a little bit
of jealousy as her poor victims get the
light squeezed out of them yeah still
what a way to go
it's a cool movie don't lose did enjoy a
good squeeze number three sill natasha
Henstridge I met her once oh there's
plenty of guys with you they met her
like a few months after speechiess came
at me what are they in trouble meeting
somebody there thank you
natasha Henstridge plays this bombshell
that's out of this world no it's not you
sure eating don't go please
I want a baby what well we can't fault
her insatiable sexual desire and smokin
hot bod this villains promiscuity is
just an excuse to get pregnant and spawn
deadly creatures and an anchor baby
would really be the least of your
worries since she kills her mates
this kind of thing doesn't usually
happen to me I'm sure you still try your
luck the way
number two Jennifer check Jennifer's
Body No Oh Megan transform from not just
another redheaded cheerleader in
Jennifer's Body she was offered up as a
sacrifice County watching man you
sacrificed big body up was your name
again Tiffany look at game is Jennifer
super not a virgin like the worshipers
were led to believe she doesn't die but
instead becomes possessed by a demon
giving her superhuman strength speed and
even the power of levitation it's really
cool to swatch look like some x-men [ __ ]
right that's right
this succubus not only kills but looks
pretty damn fine while doing it he
should retain oppose causes please give
it back crush this [ __ ] before we
unveil our topic here are a few
honorable mentions okay Charlize Theron
it's hot but an arrow of them all in
Africa the saying goes in the bush and
helmet I liked her when she was younger
that first will kill you and a black
mamba can kill you I think I can't find
you huh you got them shirts sticking out
of the door
ah yes total at this place goat I agree
way right it's the way she carries
herself number one Catherine Tramell oh
goody cake choice what happens she kills
him going full circle to round off our
list is the sizzling femme fatale
inhabited by none other than Sharon
Stone killing isn't like smoking it as
Catherine a psychotic serial killer she
uses the murders that she herself
performs to inspire her novels I'd have
to be pretty stupid to write a book
about killing and then kill somebody the
way I described it my book I'd be
announcing myself as the killer she's
best known for her iconic counter
interrogation skills as well as her
creative use of ice bags
agree with our list which sexy movie
villain gets your blood boiling a lot of
vagina I'm sorry I'm just not getting
intent like you said your name was a lot
of nevermind
for more top 10s that are easy on the
eyes and published daily be sure to
subscribe to watchmojo.com you could
take that fake apology and shove it
right up your hair okay that's a good
list I really agree with this list well
I'm gonna go jerk off if you guys are
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope yeah that's no ending joke I
gotta go